hi i'm christopher hine today we're
going to be talking about
knife disarms in aikido people are often
really excited about knife disarms
there's kind of a theory in the aikido
community right now that maybe aikido
doesn't actually have any good
disarms knife disarms and i think that's
kind of ridiculous so we're going to
talk about that today
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so knife disarms and what are
knife disarms and
why is that important to aikido people
what does that even have to do with
anything so
knife disarms are really interesting to
a lot of people because you see them in
movies a lot so because you see knife
disarms in movies you're sure that
knife disarms happen all the time then
to compound that
desire to deal with knives you you look
at youtube videos or something and you
see a real life situation where someone
tries to stab someone else
and you think yourself man if i was in
that situation i'd really like to know a
knife disarm
and that could really help me so knife
disarms can be functionally important
and of course they're exciting because
they're in movies
important thing to understand is aikido
has all the knife disarms you're ever
going to need right
so knife disarms as a whole are
contained inside of aikido
a lot of people don't believe that's
true and so they're like oh you got to
go to other martial arts systems
in order to learn knife disarms that's
not true though the core lessons are all
inside of aikido already
you probably just don't know that
they're in there now your personal
ability to
disarm a knife is dependent upon how
much you train that in a live situation
right so
no one can give you the techniques and
then you can just instantly do them
right so
and even if you train them a whole bunch
you can't just instantly do them when
someone's actually trying to stab you
with a knife
so we're going to talk today about what
those core techniques are
and then we're going to talk about the
training that you might need to do in
order to get good at those things
i'm going to call josh out here we're
going to go to work josh
all right so knife disarms let's talk
about them so knife disarms are exciting
to people because they see them in the
movies
that's super exciting and um aikido has
some knife disarms people go oh you know
i've seen a couple of demonstrations
so maybe maybe aikido has a lot of those
and that's cool
and then there's also a counterpoint to
people inside the aikido community now
who are
starting to try and look outside of
aikido for knife disarms because they
believe
aikido knife disarms are bad and there's
there's this kind of little
thing that's going on inside of aikido
that's like oh knife disarms are bad he
was no good at knife disarms
um that's a bunch of crap so uh that's
as bold as i can be about it like
so look aikido has
the basic set of fundamental techniques
that you will need for knife disarming
okay the way you disarm someone with a
knife is you first
weaken their grip and then you take the
knife out of their hand so that's the
most direct way right and of course
there's other ways punch them in the
face and maybe they'll let go of it all
kinds of other stuff could happen
but as far as directly taking something
out of someone's hand
you're going to weaken the grip and take
it out so let me show you what i mean
with that so if josh has this knife here
okay if i were able to pull on the knife
this way it wouldn't be a very
successful way to pull on the knife
right so because he's strong right i
won't be able to pull it so it's it's
hard for me to get that out of his hand
unless of course he opens his hand like
he just did
right then he can get it out of there
right and that's what happens a lot of
times the demonstrations is the uk knows
they're supposed to let go so they just
open their hand the guy was oh look
and you could disarm any way right and
that would have worked but
in order to get this out of his hand i
need to first weaken his grip so what
are the ways i could weaken his grip
well i want to lengthen the ligaments in
his arm as much as i possibly can
to make his grip weak right so the
ligaments in his arm only go so far
and then once those have been stretched
to their max he will have a hard time
gripping something right it'll be real
hard for him to grab something one of
the ways to link
those ligaments is to twist the wrist
this way right so by twisting it i'm
really stretching out everything is
in his arm here and that grip's getting
weaker and weaker and weaker until it
gets to a point where it's relatively
easy to take out of the hand right now
that's relative to how strong this guy
is how used to having his arm twisted
this way is but as far as
you know an average person that's going
to be the way to totally get it out of
their hand
okay now another way to get it out is to
turn it over this way
and i can turn it here and again i've
lengthened all those ligaments in this
form and it's easy to get that knife out
of his hand right
okay another way i could do it is i
could fold this wrist down
totally flat like this so those are the
basic core ways okay now
in aikido we call this way to lengthen
these ligaments in his
arm cottage right kotte is wrist geisha
means to turn over so i'm turning over
the wrist right here and that's how i'm
lengthening those
to get that out if we turn it this way
and add a little upward pressure we call
that
knee kyo right so that's second
principle if i turn it all the way this
way
that becomes sankyo right so third
principle
so those are the core ways now i can
also fold his wrist down like this we
call this gokyo this is fifth lesson
and it comes out of the hand so those
are the ways in which you're going to
weaken the arm and get something out of
someone's hand and you can see we have
all of those in aikido and in fact not
only do we have them
they are major techniques so when you
hear the word kyo in aikido that means a
principle
so ikyo through rokyo are our six major
principles
now you can see that we have three of
those right here and then also kotagaich
which is one of aikido's major
techniques
which is this to turn the wrist over
that is also included in these
now if you look at video of any other
knife system doing disarms of this
flavor right so meaning to directly take
it out which is the most common way to
disarm something
you're going to see those four things
over and over right so
you're going to see cottage you're going
to see goku you're going to say nikkio
and you're going to see santio so those
are the four things you're going to see
repeatedly
doesn't matter if you look at filipino
knife disarms european knife disarms
chinese knife disarms doesn't matter
what
if we're taking something out of the
hand those are the four ways you're
going to do it
those are four principles in aikido okay
now those
principles aside how are we actually
going to do that right so
that's the rough technique right so the
rough technique is to
uh manipulate his arm into one of those
those ways
but how am i actually then going to take
it out okay now if we look at cloth the
guys
cut in cottage the technique commonly in
most schools looks something like this
right this is a very common way to do a
quote the geish
now what's happening in the quilt the
guys this hand that's towards the handle
is pushing the knife like this okay this
hand
is pulling the knife like this when we
put those together we get a good way to
pop the knife out of someone's hand
so in a classic clip the guys technique
that's practiced all over in aikido
schools
we're pushing on this side pulling on
this side and that's our knife disarm
now unfortunately we're from a culture
that's currently obsessed with unarmed
martial arts why we're obsessed with our
martial arts
i don't know but in that we're sure that
cult the guys is this and you see all
kinds of weird applications people
pushing their thumbs in
all kinds of weird things people will
complain about crossing your thumbs or
all these weird things
this is weird obsession about tiny
minutia that's not important to the
technique
grossly the technique goes like this now
when you see it in its proper
application which is not an unarmed
application
it's done like this and that's wrenching
something out of someone's hand now i
could do that if he had a spear in his
hand
if he had a bow and arrow in his hand if
he had a gun in his hand if he had a
knife it doesn't matter what he has in
his hand
i can disarm in that method and that's
an aikido method a common aikido method
nico all right now in a lot of schools
you will see things like this
right so you see where they're popping
the knife out of someone's hand like
that
and they're going against the blade and
popping it out and you'll see that in
filipino systems you see it in
chinese system you see all kinds of ways
all right in aikido we have essentially
that same technique
but it's done with the side of your
shoulder like this okay
and that's called nico and that's a very
classic application of nico to get
something out of someone's hand
okay now it might scare you to see the
knife blade is near my body right
when you're dealing with knives the
knife is going to be near your body it's
a close range situation if you've lost
all of your ability to keep my eye good
distancing then you're
you're going to see that over and over
again the knife is close to the body
now if the knife is close to the body i
want it part near a part of the body
that it's not going to hurt me
as opposed to near a part of the body
where it's going to hurt me right so
i'm putting it in one of the best places
i possibly could put it and then i'm
going to use my body to crank that knife
out of there right so
that disarm which is very common to lots
of styles of martial arts
is also existent in aikido right
for sankyo maybe come to this side for
me for sankyo let's say we're working
the arm down here i'm going to try to
avoid my microphone so sorry if it goes
loud for you
so i'm right here like this okay now
what am i going to do well he's going to
be moving his arm all over right so if i
get to this position
i can crank with my whole body this way
to apply
sankyo now again when we're in obsessive
culture
right our culture's obsessed with our
martial arts then we see this and this
is
ah sankyo looks like that so it must be
a wrist lock and we don't ever stop to
think that it's
me putting both my hands on the knife
and turning as hard as i can
to drive that knife back towards this
guy right so
that is what um aikido kyowasa
techniques are trying to do to make the
disarms and you can see those
constantly throughout the techniques of
aikido they're all over the place
now if you're good at them or not is is
what's important so how do you get good
at that
well you need a set of drills to help
you get good at that let's call maya out
and see if she can help us
all right so uh now we got our two
trainers out here
and i got a bum knee so i'm no good for
this all right so we're going to talk
about some methods to train you to be
better at
disarming now we've already shown some
of these these basic techniques
but we're going to kind of get into a
little bit more of a live practice with
it so you guys can see a little more
now right now we're using a dull still
steel trainer right so actually this is
aluminum trainer
um there is no edge on this at all right
it's flat flat flatter than
the back of a normal knife right so it's
super super flat all the edges have been
rounded
so it's purpose built for this training
i will still
say when you start training live with
this stuff that
steel is is really still hard on your
body if you get whacked real hard like
this it still is no fun
wood is a little better than that rubber
is way better than that the
and foam is even better yet than that
the problem with that is
as the knife becomes really flexible
then a lot of stuff where you're pushing
on the blade
um will not be available to you because
in foam your hand just goes through and
doesn't disarm anything
rubber not much better wood works pretty
good
so you choose the trainer that's
appropriate for what you're doing
okay so first thing we're going to talk
about is we're going to have maya go
through just some basic disarm
techniques with josh now we are using a
knife and this
video is specifically built towards um
uh
working with knife disarms although
these can be done for anything you're
gonna see these basic ways that we've
done before
in other videos right so so in this
so first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna have maya place her hands on josh
right so right on that knife there
somewhere all right so now she's got a
hole to the knife
now she always wants to grab with two
actually let me have you switch guys the
other hand real quick just so they can
see this
okay so she always wants to be working
two on the on the one now
here's why because now she's got a
slight strength advantage right so josh
would have to be twice as strong with
this one arm as maya is with her two
arms in order for
him to be stronger than her okay the
second reason for that is
there's always the potential for him to
switch that knife so if her hand wasn't
there he could easily switch that knife
over
that's no good so she always wants one
hand blocking the opening of his hands
whenever she's working a knife disarm
one hand's always covering the opening
of his hand um so that's a real
important
set to get into and ignore techniques
almost always account for this in
exactly this way
all right now what she wants to do is
figure out ways to disarm so this is
just a real chill practice
where maya is working through how if i
had josh like this
could i get the knife out and she's
going to work through a few different
situations
okay she got a coat of geish there
she got enikio there
and another coat of guys right okay so
you can see she just let her work
through this right so she can work
through a
ton of different ones and there's no
stress in this situation so she can
actually see the techniques of aikido
formulating her head where she needs to
go to to to disarm that technique okay
now we're going to move up from this so
next we're going to create a situation
where maybe josh was cutting at her so
he's going to start out in this position
and maya's already got a defensive
position up okay now
look this is normal maybe this looks
crazy to you if you're obsessed with
unarmed martial arts but for uh for our
martial arts this is super normal this
guy tried to cut into her she stuck her
hand
up like this because she was freaked out
and so that's the position they they got
into
okay now from here what josh is going to
do is really casually
move the knife around to cut maya okay
so that's what he's trying to do he's
moving it around
cut my mind's just going to flow with it
wherever he moves it around just like
that
perfect okay now what's going to happen
is maya from this kind of real chilled
out practice is going to go
close in and try to get to that two on
one position and then make
that into the disarm right you saw right
when she clicked into gear right so
you saw it she was kind of moving slow
she didn't know and then the second her
body got to the position she knew
she boom disarmed that sucker right okay
that's what we're looking to train and
that should come from that first
practice
the very first practice there we go
where she's learning ah that's a good
position for me to get kodagaish right
so now when we translate that to the
second drill
we're still no stress here she's moving
around she starts to see that same exact
position
and there she goes now she knows how to
get the nico out right so really easy
stepwise progression
and that's slow but adds a little more
stress now understand
it's not a big deal but it's a little
bit of stress so we're getting her mind
used to dealing with stress
now from this real chilled out practice
we're going to go to a slightly faster
practice
where josh is just moving faster from
the same situation
there we go we got that same technique
out okay now
from that we're going to go to a
practice where they don't have
connection and this should look really
similar to aikido people this is often
called
jiawaza right so this is a geo was a
practice where josh is going to really
lightly
give some very simple strikes now look
these are the the strikes that no one
thinks are any good because
they're used to unarmed martial arts
culture but cutting like this is normal
cutting like this is normal
cutting like this is normal so now that
we got a knife in the hand these should
be very normal strikes
josh is going to lightly move around
with maya maya's going to try to get
into defended position so as they're
moving around she's going to try to
defend and keep that knife from getting
to her and then she's going to try to
get to the position that she knows she
can disarm from
all right so we see that practice next
now notice now josh is not just waiting
for her to take it out of his hand
but he's also not really actively trying
to mess her up right he's not trying to
hurt her
to really get her or make her feel
stupid right and so maya's having to
work through these different scenarios
right
every time she's looking for that same
position and then once she's comfortable
she's gonna work that disarm all right
so
this is no resistance from josh as far
as when maya's trying to apply the
technique no resistance from josh at all
um all he's doing now is add the
spontaneity of he's gonna do some
different kinds of cuts so he's trying
some different stabs in there
cutting in different directions but for
maya once we get to this basic kind of
position she should already have some
programming for that now of course she
should also have programming from here
and also programming from here and you
can work all those things in as you go
but now because josh is coming in in a
variety of different ways she can then
get to the position and learn to disarm
from there okay now what we're going to
do is we're going to do that same exact
practice
at the same speed i hope but now josh is
actually going to try to resist a little
bit so
when maya goes to take it out of his arm
he can recover his arm he can try and
push her off and mine's still going to
try to work those same disarms okay same
speed though so still pretty mellow
she got a nico there
nico again
uh he switched their honor good all
right very good all right
so you can see this is still super light
we're still being super cool no one's
really trying to get anyone
but we're giving he's giving her more
and more difficulty as we progress right
so there he switched the knife or she
gets it he kind of tries to pull his
hand free he's not making it easy for
her
as we're going to this okay now next
we're going to go ahead and grab a
plastic trainer
okay video magic we're back with the
plastic trainer here so it's a rubber
trainer
and the reason i switched to this is
because we're gonna amp it up now and so
look it's not really as good for maya to
practice the specifics of disarming
which is kind of some of the stuff we
already worked right now
with this knife because it's soft so
meaning she pushes on the blade at all
it's going to give and so it's not
really great for practicing the actual
disarming
manipulations but now we do this because
i want josh to more actively come in to
actually stab and cut at maya
and so if maya takes too many with this
piece of steel
it's really bad right so we've all come
away with tons of little bruises and
some little injuries and
teeth get endangered all kinds of things
happen so i've gone to rubber so that
way it's just easier for us to do can
you never do the same practice but i'm
asked josh to amp it up a little bit
more and so now he's actually going to
actively try and keep maya from getting
it now he's still going to actively
give cuts so he's not going to fence
right he's not going to stay in this
position he's not going to be dodgy
he's still just going to move in and
he's going to give cuts but every time
she gets a hold of he's going to try to
recover his hand
and keep her from getting it so he's not
trying to facilitate her disarming
anymore
now he's facilitating her getting to a
stable position
that maybe she could disarm from all
right so let's give that a try
good josh going to give a real hard time
now there we go
all right yummy we're way off camera
okay all right so that's totally fine
all right so
uh so there we're starting to amp up now
we could still go a little harder
they're being a little sweet to each
other right now because they want to
make a video right so
but you can see how that's going to amp
up and amp up and amp up and that's what
we want we want to amp up
now as we make that sacrifice for
trainers
he's going to focus more on stabbing her
working that knife more
and he's going to focus more on moving
his body around and getting free
as opposed to before where he was pretty
much giving her the knife but allowing
her to really work the details of the
disarm
so now we're a progression up okay now
from here
a lot of people are probably going to
ask like well so
josh should be kg and dodgy right okay
so meaning the way he should do is he
should have the knife in a defended
position
right so like that he's in a defended
position and he should be trying to keep
maya out every time maya comes in so go
ahead and fake coming in right and then
he should try and grab her and stab her
up right okay and
and that's a valid thing all right now
the problem for this is
in the system of aikido we don't run
into someone with a knife so if josh
goes into a defended position switch so
they can see the knife
josh goes into offended position we
train maya to never
run into this position she should never
run into this position
so in the system of aikido she should
just never practice this so
if josh gets dodgy and kg like this maya
will just stand back
and and it will be a very boring minute
or however long we run the scenario
because um she doesn't want to ever run
into this position
now what that will do if josh wants to
engage is draw
josh out of a defended position and into
an
offensive position so you see here he's
gone into an offensive position
now this looks a lot more like the drill
and then from this he's gonna cut okay
now we can run a full-on scenario and
we'll run one for you here right now
okay we're gonna run a full-on scenario
and you can see what's going on where
josh is actually doing that
and every time josh is cagey mine should
be training herself to stay out of that
distance and then when josh is provoked
into
coming for her then the aikido
techniques will naturally appear okay so
i'm going to get out of frame here and
let these guys go we're going to go for
a minute on them
and we'll see what we get
[Music]
so
good job all right so there you have the
the final version of that drill one of
the things you'll notice in that is maya
spent most of her time
trying to stay at a distance and that's
because that's what she wants to do is
stay at a distance
it's dangerous when you get in close
with that knife right a knife and a
small action can end your life
so she doesn't want to grapple with that
guy if she can avoid it now only when
the situation gets pressed in so much
that getting out is not an option
anymore will maya try and transition to
a set of skills that allows her to take
the knife out
but again she's not trying to grapple
with this guy understand she's
envisioning a scenario where this guy is
bigger than her stronger than her better
train than her all that stuff
so she doesn't want to mess around with
it if she can get a quick disarm she
will and you saw a couple in there she
got a couple disarms right
so that's not getting disarms is not
like in the movies where every time
someone
stabs in with you you can train yourself
to perfectly get out of the way and
disarm that's
not going to happen in an actual live
practice now in a grappling practice
where you start out at grappling range
and the knife comes out you're going to
get to do more of that disarm now that
practice is strictly outside of aikido
and on this channel we've done that
practice for you guys you can see it
if you want to see a comment below and
we'll we'll put in more of those
um but those are the basic techniques
you're going to use they already exist
in aikido and the basic ways they're
going to come up
pretty much already exist in aikido so
outside of studying a grappling system
aikido does what it needs to do for
disarms
knife disarms aren't as magical as you
think they are right so
in the movies they look real cool but in
real life they don't actually come up
all that often you might get one it
might save your life they're good to
know
good to practice but they shouldn't be
the be all end all of your training
you're never going to train yourself to
the level
where every time someone stabs you with
a knife you catch their hand and you
twist it out of their hand then
you're the victorious guy with the knife
also important to understand on the
other side because you see this a lot
where aikido people
say like oh man you should never use a
knife in a fight because what if they
take the knife from you
which is the most insane logic on earth
you see in that where josh
very seldomly had the knife taken from
him right so moving quickly recovering
the knife as fast you can
making good cuts and getting out of
there that's what you should be doing
when you have the knife and if you do
that most of the time you're probably
not going to be disarmed
so i'm christopher hine i hope that shed
a little light on knife disarms for you
take care
[Music]